depuis le début de l'été les
déplacements ministériels se sont
multipliées dans les yvelines
dernière en date mercredi 19 août au
val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie avec la
visite de brigitte clincker la ministre
déléguée chargée de l'insertion est venu
échanger avec les élus locaux et
associatifs et aussi observer les bonnes
pratiques en matière d'emplois sur le
territoire
il est important pour moi de venir dans
les territoires tout simplement parce
que je suis également élu local élus de
terrain et que c'est dans les
territoires en étant à l'écouté des
différents acteurs des différents
partenaires et des élus et bien que l'on
apprend que l'on se rend compte des
spécificités des territoires et des
richesses et parmi ces richesses une
initiative locale intéresse
particulièrement le gouvernement le pair
à pair des heures de garde d'enfants
gratuite pour les demandeurs d'emploi un
dispositif gagnant gagnant puisque les
baby-sitters sont eux mêmes en insertion
une action portée par l'association pour
la formation professionnelle l'afpi qui
met en relation ces personnes avec le
soutien de l'agencé départementale
d'insertion activity c'est une action
qui a démarré en 2010 8,8 à au constat
de la difficulté de trouver un mode de
garde dans l'urgence lorsqu'on a un
entretien une rentrée en formation ou un
emploi qui démarre et du coup on avait
beaucoup de gens qui souhaitaient
rentrer dans les métiers de la petite
enfance et pas d'opportunité soit par
manque d'expérience parce qu'il ya
longtemps qu'elle n'avait pas travaillé
soit par manque de formation
j'ai été ému par ce que je me suis rendu
compte que ces personnes sans la fille
sans
toute l'énergie qui a déployé par cette
structure est bien n'aurait pas pu
trouver d'emploi
parce que il ya des freins et parmi ces
freins le mode de garde est un frein qui
est considérable en 2018 25 familles ont
bénéficié du dispositif une solution
innovante qui va servir à nourrir la
réflexion de la ministre au tour des
freins d'accès à l'emploi
cette semaine le gouvernement a par
ailleurs débloqué une enveloppe de 300
millions d'euros pour soutenir les
entreprises sociales inclusive fortement
impacté par la crise sanitaire